hi i'm steven crowder and I'm Alfonso
Rachel and we're Republicans haha
when I'm not working inside trading
deals or adding to my yacht collection I
like to spend my free time stepping on
the workingman
that's right Steven and when I'm not
working as a mouthpiece for the greedy
corporations I like putting my money
into offshore accounts and cheating on
my taxes well we do do that so you bet
we do
Oh careful Alfonso not too close well
why is that scene well it's nothing
personal
I'm just deathly afraid of black people
oh of course
Steve I'm so sorry and it's totally
understandable it is well of course I am
a self-loathing Uncle Tom I almost
forgot all black Republicans are
traitors to their own race
I think I'll Sharpton nailed that one
right in the heads up oh well that's one
of the things he said right I am afraid
of my own blackness well that's good
because I'm getting cold sweats just
looking at you though well that's
understandable and to be expected oh no
there'll be no physical contact so well
why is that Steve have you forgotten all
lost Republicans fear the gays you got
that right Nancy Pelosi said it best
when we just hate anybody who's
different from us I hate myself oh I
hate your twos Oh Oh a white one oh I
forgot you do love the white lady so I
certainly do Steve
you know me all too well hey hey Chuck's
could you get me a SmartWater and would
you like anything's up aperi would be
lovely see a pair yay for my black
friend get it yourself did you see that
so I most certainly did Steve what
happened to being subservient you see
folks we're Republicans yearning for the
good old days when a lady's fat lip was
the sign of a poorly made sandwich don't
get the kind of service anymore no we
don't and it's a shame it's a crying
shame
but as ketover will tell you to a
conservative men women are only good for
one thing overpopulation
I bet eight kids at home and I'm working
on a ninth right now really I've got 14
of my own Oh my 14 did you not have a TV
though ha ha ha stop it no well you know
we Republicans have big families for one
and one reason only we can't stand the
environment I hate that the truth big
guy there's nothing we like more than
watching a guy I get torn apart by the
scourge of man
I Drive a u-haul to and from work every
day
well that's clubbers though oh it looks
for almost out of time already I know
but do you have any last words for our
undecided a politically minded Schmucks
at home you know see I think I do if you
want to find out more about Republicans
just like us you just tuned in to MSNBC
that's right
they'll show you the real face of the
Republican Party what face is that you
ask
well buttercup you're looking at it ah
all right man I feel pretty good about
that take I think we nailed it yeah yeah
you know it's it's hard as a progressive
actor to get into this conservatively
warped character but I thought that came
across as genuine it's all good show for
sure let's get over to Keith over his
man he's got that party going on in
there coming out at 8 o'clock oh my god
I hear he has the best margaritas I
don't think it's safe to be drunk around
you oh you stop it you better stop it